Posso registrarti Maurice vero? Si si. Perfetto. Ti va di rispiegare che livello di integrazione
dell'AI vorresti nella piattaforma WeDo? Ok io pensavo ad un'integrazione di tipo
predittivo. Cosa vuol dire? Vuol dire che l'utente inserisce per dire come informazione
base il proprio indirizzo di residenza. Quindi quello sarà un punto degli ipotetici due e
la retta che si verrà a formare potrà essere il raggio d'azione predittivo dell'AI. Cosa
vuol dire? Vuol dire che se l'utente, vogliamo dire l'elettricista, inserisce i suoi appuntamenti
analogici nell'agenda, quindi se l'utente inserisce i suoi appuntamenti analogici nell'agenda,
quindi un appuntamento alle 10 di mattina fino a mezzogiorno in un punto A, un secondo
appuntamento alle 14 fino alle 16 in un punto B, la nostra piattaforma potrà suggerire
all'elettricista sia dei task da mezzogiorno alle 14 lungo il tragitto da A a B e poi terminato
il lavoro.
Il lavoro pomeridiano, quindi con un timer, da una certa ora in poi comincerà a monitorare
e suggerire all'utente dei task dal punto in cui si trova fino al ritorno alla propria
residenza.
Certo, ma secondo me è da fare perché uno mette le sue fasce libere e si ottenerà, giusto?
Sì, esatto.
E le sue competenze, la piattaforma già lo sa e va a unire la domanda e l'offerta grazie
anche al pricing dinamico.
Esatto, e poi diciamo che a questo punto si potrà prevedere sempre nell'iscrizione una
serie di informazioni, anche tante, compilabili o meno a discrezione dell'utente.
Sì, esatto.
Però informandolo che quante più informazioni darà, tanto più sarà fatto su misura di
servizio.
Quindi se l'utente dà l'indirizzo di casa, l'indirizzo di lavoro, banalmente gli orari
in cui è inizio.
Il filtro, ho bisogno di un metro e sessanta minuti o posso aspettare fino a domani?
Cambia tanto la disponibilità?
Esatto.
Esatto, quindi rendere il tutto fluido.
Nella misura in cui uno magari dice, ce l'ho bisogno subito, ma posso aspettare anche
fino a domani.
Oppure no, ce l'ho bisogno soltanto ora.
Una cosa di questo tipo.
Quindi dà all'utente anche un po' più di libertà e ci toglie un affanno che non necessariamente
ci dobbiamo caricare di default.
Perché magari l'utente è abituato a aspettare una volta.
La settimana, quindi aspettare un giorno già per lui è una vittoria totale.
Uno ora non se lo immagina neanche.
No, no.
E poi è molto semplice.
Se l'utente si mette anche le sue fasce di disponibilità e il luogo, che lo sa già
il database, le hai per fare un matching della madonna.
E ti può fare esatto il matching del mattino per il pomeriggio e quindi riesce a ottimizzare
enormemente tutti i processi e quindi a soddisfare magari una richiesta con una minore offerta.
Perché comunque riesce in qualche modo a spalmarla un po' nell'arco della giornata.
Diventa predittiva per l'utente, quindi magari suggerisce cose che uno diversamente non andrebbe
a ricercare.
Anche viceversa.
Perché magari...
L'artigiano dice, vabbè, vi faccio 15 chilometri, però c'è un bel lavoro.
Esatto.
Sì, sì, sì.
Però quantomeno l'intelligenza artificiale può suggerire anche queste due opzioni.
Diversamente magari uno prenderebbe solo...
Quello che ha una mentalità meno imprenditoriale ne prenderebbe solo una.
Invece Giannini dice, guarda, tu a fare questa cosa guadagni 50 euro.
Però se ti spaventa...
Se ti sposti 5 chilometri più in là, ne guadagni 100.
Certo.
Beh, dai, allora...
La metto già nel piano.
Diciamo che con l'intelligenza artificiale viene fuori la macchina definitiva.
Perché a quel punto ottimizzerebbe le entrate di chiunque in maniera passiva da parte dell'utente.
Quindi figurati.
Potrebbe essere anche interessante mettere magari anche...
Delle necessità continue di piccole cose che uno lo mette.
Sai, magari se è un interessato, se costa poco, pack.
Esatto.
E gli arriva la proposta.
E avevo pensato sempre rispetto al tema gamification.
Se ci fosse nella pagina dell'utente, magari a fine giornata o durante la giornata,
un contatore che dice...
Se avessi risposto a tre dei task che ti ho proposto, avresti guadagnato 30 euro in più.
Così uno a fine giornata, quando vede un giorno 50, l'altro giorno 70,
magari si invoglia anche a dar fiducia.
E dice, sai che oggi seguo l'applicazione.
Come la vedi?
Beh, che attualmente sono i tassisti che lavorano per Uber.
Esatto.
Cioè, addirittura Uber ormai ha le macchine e cerca i lottisti dipendenti, per dire.
Non avete un futuro di avere il migliore elettricista di Milano.
Esatto, esatto.
L'Elite Squad, i migliori con Guido.
Qualcosa del genere.
Esatto, esatto.
Ma...
Ma secondo me questa pagina...
Questa parte è proprio la svolta.
Allora, non voglio nasconderti che va bene, avere l'AI oggi, fate bene,
finché costa un sacco di soldi.
Però...
Però se divento co-founder, volentieri.
Io ti dico, sarei felicissimo di...
Anche io di lavorare con te, sinceramente.
Anche perché questo rischia, secondo me,
di venire fuori un bel progetto e messo insieme con persone, le conoscerai poi...
Volentieri, certo.
A parte tutte di gran valore, ma poi persone che, lo vedrai, quando ci parli ti si aprono altre 20 opportunità lavorative
che uno dice, cazzo, qua si può fare il botto anche in altre 10 strade, no?
Ah beh, sì, sì.
Ma secondo me il team vincente e le mie idee innovative sull'utilizzo dell'AI,
che veramente è un anno che ci...
Anzi, ti ho mandato via WhatsApp un preprint di un paper che vorrei pubblicare,
ma ho qualche difficoltà a pubblicarlo perché, vabbè, non ho un dottorato ma nemmeno una laurea.
Però ormai è una bella bozza, ma...
L'inglese tu lo sai bene, quindi capirei bene cosa dice.
Il coautore che vedi è il mio zio d'America, che invece lui ce l'ha dottorato,
solo che adesso non ha tempo per questa cosa, che lui attualmente pubblica nell'AI
e ha detto, cazzo, mi fai l'endorsement, co-pubblichi tu e mi fai pubblicare il mio primo articolo.
Che poi mi sembra che se ne pubblichi 5...
Che figata!
Poi anche...
No, come non...
Poi anche ottenere un dottorato in omaggio, mi pare.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, dopo me lo leggo, me lo leggo super volentieri.
E io, in tutto quello che faccio, ma applico questo protocollo, chiamiamolo orchidea,
che è per gestire la relazione umana-AI al massimo, per il massimo beneficio di entrambi.
Certo.
Quindi, ti dico, secondo me con questa parte qua facciamo il botto.
Anche secondo me.
E allora, da un punto di vista pratico,
io, ti dico, sono già iper felice e iper convinto.
Quello che operativamente sono i punti che dobbiamo capire un attimo come fare è
tu hai fatto le condizioni economiche, firma avvio, metà fase 1 e poi via via,
chiusura fase 1, chiusura fase 2.
E a me sta benissimo.
Quello che è il tema...
...è che il Startax l'altro giorno ha detto
qua c'è da costituire una società ad hoc, quindi che sarà la start-up.
E lui diceva, io vi suggerisco, dato che siamo a fine novembre...
...di farla a gennaio.
Fate la a gennaio perché banalmente avrete degli addempimenti X da gestire,
che diversamente non dovreste fare per l'anno in corso, con i relativi costi.
Quindi noi eravamo rimasti d'accordo con lui che la società l'avremmo aperta a gennaio.
Di conseguenza questa parte qua dobbiamo capire, devo capire io operativamente, se posso.
Ma Maurizio, allora, ci conosciamo da tanti anni e...
...ma anche se fossero 18 milioni di euro sarebbe un mese e mezzo di lavoro.
Eh, questo è...
Per me iniziare subito e poi formalizzare, allora diciamo, pre-formalizziamo una cosa tra di noi,
poi il discorso di accolto e altre cose, anche se si fa a gennaio, non è un problema.
Non ti nascondo che sarebbe più comodo a me averle a dicembre finiti con salti,
però magari anche gli esperti di start-up hanno già qualche soluzione, che ne so, una profonda.
Certo.
Che almeno me la mettono, solo per metterla a bilancio, tutto lì.
Sì, sì, sì, chiaro. Ecco, io questa cosa qua la posso verificare e penso che comunque in un modo o nell'altro sia smarcabile.
Ti dico, perché la parte più pionerosa, anche in termini di sviluppo, è proprio l'inizio, ok?
Quindi dovrò comunque delegare tante tante parti, ok?
Certo.
Cioè per routine, mi so, perché poi a chi deleghi non vede nemmeno a cosa sta lavorando, capito?
Quando tu chiedi una routine, che deve fare questa cosa qui, lui non vede né il nome né la start-up, insomma.
Però appunto dovrò foraggiare un bel po' di sviluppatori.
E non nascondo che mi viene comodo avere, almeno a livello di bilancio, averle comunque, visto che lavoro delle uscite,
che per un mese e mezzo posso anche anticipare, non è assolutamente un problema.
Si sudama proprio il tema di contabilità.
Contabilità pur, esatto. Visto che ho le uscite io ce le ho subito, perché comunque i freelance li pago bene, li pago subito,
li pago ogni settimana su avanzamenti, per quello corrono, altrimenti non fanno un cazzo.
Certo.
Quindi, allora, aspetta.
Fammi pensare, perché sono 35 mila, il 30% sono 3-6 no, 10.500 e che sono la prima tranche a firma di Dio.
La metà fase, se noi partissimo subito, la metà fase 1 invece l'avremo quando?
Ma potremmo averla entro fine anno e primi di gennaio.
Certo.
E' una cosa che a livello di cash flow non mi interessa che sia dicembre o gennaio, assolutamente.
A livello invece contabile, se riesco a avere il quest'anno fiscale è meglio, perché tutti quanti ovviamente
poi a fine anno vogliono aumentare cose, quindi per me spingere adesso è meglio che a gennaio.
Sì, sì, no, ma io sto facendo adesso questi conti perché voglio capire con loro, gli dico,
io ho un costo che dovrei sostenere da qui a fine anno di 21.000 euro.
Magari loro mi dicono che tanto io questo costo non l'avrei recuperato, no?
Allora a quel punto gli dico, bene, allora lo sostengo io come persona fisica e poi…
Come già, ma se vuoi anche alla fine, eh.
Sì, sì, no, ma…
Implementazione marketing, posso metterti quello che vuoi.
Poi dopo a gennaio partiamo correttamente con le cose.
Fare tutto quanto preciso preferisco anch'io, eh, figurati.
Cioè, Ale, così dici, se diventa una cosa… Sì, beh, così potrebbe essere anche un tema, eh.
Cioè, se vuoi scaricarti spese con Javas, ti servono costi, io l'occasione fosse in te la sfrutterei
e sarei io a chiedere a te, non è che mi fai la fattura sull'altra società.
Visto che l'altra non c'è entrate, eh.
Certo, sì, sì, sì. No, allora facciamo così.
Io adesso questa cosa la ragiono, ma nelle prossime ore.
Io poi domani vedo Costanza, la mia altra socia in battaglia,
quella che ti dicevo, lei ti aveva accennato che mi aveva presentato
questa Valentina, aspetta, il cognome, che magari la conosci, sai chi è,
Ingellis, lei da quello che ho capito è una project manager, più che altro, no?
Lei non ha competenze tecniche e lei aveva detto che, insomma,
le sarebbe piaciuto entrare nel progetto e quant'altro, però è inutile dirti
che io voglio farlo con te, questa cosa.
Quindi domani racconterò a Costanza, le dico, guarda, è così quello che è,
Francesco, vuoi? Collaboriamo, ci conosciamo da 15 anni,
quindi c'è il rapporto personale oltre che lavorativo,
e vuoi che queste cose lui lo sa fare materialmente,
quindi sa se vengono fatte bene o male, quali sono tutti i valori aggiunti,
insomma, quindi è pura pro forma e quindi io direi già io domani sera
riesco a dirti, riusciamo a partire subito.
Oh, che figo!
No, io, guarda, sarebbe forse il momento dove negli ultimi tre mesi
mi metto il cuore in pace, almeno per una notte, perché so che sta partendo,
quindi...
Sono qui che proprio sto facendo mille ragionamenti,
ma sono mille ragionamenti su come fare le cose, no? Subito.
Quindi bene, bene, bene.
Dai, bello, sono davvero contento.
No, secondo me è così come la stiamo definendo,
con tutta quella parte anche di supporto,
di suggerimento, eccetera, via da fuori una cosa.
Tra l'altro, sai perché sto registrando, Maurice?
Perché nei miei primi esperimenti del protocollo Ortidea,
alla fine, l'Iterazione Umano AI,
ho iniziato anche a fare delle prove dandole le fotografie dei fogli di bozze
fatti tra persone, le fotografie delle nascoste, dei pennarelli,
e poi ho iniziato a registrare l'audio delle riunioni,
perché devo stare a fare io un lavoro
che lei lo fa in un minuto e lo fa benissimo,
di trascrivere un audio.
Certo.
E non devo neanche più prendere appunti.
Sì, sì, sì, no, è fighissimo.
Infatti...
Ti integro quello che siamo detti oggi al Word direttamente.
Certo. No, no, ma è spettacolare.
Ma tu immagina, se pensi, quanto è visionaria
questa applicazione?
Perché fondamentalmente può decentralizzare l'economia.
Vero, vero.
E quanto è attuale,
seppur tirando fuori cose che quasi stanno morendo,
perché giusto l'altro giorno ho visto al telegiornale,
dicono stanno chiudendo migliaia di negozi,
perché ormai l'online ha fregato tutti.
Però se tu crei...
È la rivincita dell'artigiano, diciamo, del negoziante.
Esatto, esatto.
È praticamente portare l'artigiano a giocarsela con i big
dandogli uno strumento che mima le loro potenzialità.
Adesso è bella, mi è venuto questo lampo adesso.
Poi dico, in un futuro che diventa semodulare
anche sulla fornitura a chilometro zero di quartiere...
Sì.
Questo è interessante.
Ma io ti ho messo questa parte perché l'ho tagliata a un certo punto per...
No, vabbè, no, perché l'app diventa faccio tutto.
No, ma sai che io a un certo punto avevo previsto anche il baratto.
E gli dicevo, magari una felpa che io non metto più.
Dico, vabbè, dai, chi mi lava la macchina,
gli do questa felpa in cambio.
Eh, non è molto...
È da brainstorming, alla fine, quello che stiamo facendo.
Comunque, in fase così di iniziale bisogna farlo.
We do.
Ma guarda come dire Uber quando a un certo punto si sono messi a, non lo so,
a consegnare le pizze, a far volare i droni, a tutto quanto.
È perché quando ormai hanno budget infinito
ci pompano dentro mille funzionalità o mille cose in più.
Quindi una fase iniziale.
E poi il mercato accoglie.
Può andar bene, può andar male.
Esatto.
E uno la mette, la toglie e non si accorge nessuno
perché tanto nessuno dirà...
Sì, magari lo dice, ah, va che cagata che ha messo,
però non la guardi e dopo un po' sparisce da sola.
Quindi si potrà anche provare nel futuro di mettere anche la funzionalità baratto.
Sì, sì, ma fondamentalmente un quartiere potrebbe
vivere con il mutuo scambio, se ci pensi.
Sì, sì, sì.
Questa cosa comunque della linea microeconomia parallela
è secondo me per il marketing è da spingere.
Ma non solo, cioè te la butto lì ancora più visionaria.
Se l'intelligenza artificiale riuscisse anche a,
una volta in cui si dà ai negozi,
ma negozi botteghe,
la possibilità di condividere le loro liste della spesa con i fornitori
potrebbe creare gruppi d'acquisto.
Quindi in una città come Milano
i 50 lattai potrebbero comprare come un'unica società
con i prezzi a sconto della grossa distribuzione.
Allora liberamente la metti nel culo a tutti.
Da quant'è che ci pensi?
Voi avete visto, non mi ricordo,
me l'avete già detto, ma non mi ricordo.
Forse sì, l'avevo già...
È un po', non un anno, ma qualche mese, un po' di mesi mi sembra, vero?
Eh, ci sta.
Da quanto che ci pensi tu a WeDo?
Da...
Ci penso come...
Come bozza...
Come idea, come idea.
La prima volta che hai detto ah, senti che idea mi è venuta.
Proprio così, dal principio.
Come bozza un po' di mesi fa.
Immagino allora le notti insonni.
Soprattutto quando pensi poi di realizzarla e vuoi farlo
e ti accorgi dei muri che ci sono,
veramente inizi a interpensare.
Sì, più che altro
allora è un bel esercizio
perché poi pensi come semplificare le cose
al punto di renderle fattibili.
Quindi continui a stremare.
L'idea la espandi e dopo la ricomprimi.
Però se ci pensi la parte di centralizzazione degli acquisti
per l'intelligenza artificiale cosa sarebbe?
Tagliata.
Eh, no.
Eh, però per gli utenti che vanno raggiunti.
È un plus della madonna.
Non mi sembra, guarda, dicevano 1.400 attività commerciali all'anno
spariscono in Italia.
Quindi perché?
Perché non riescono a fare i conti con la grande distribuzione.
Così se uno gli comincia a dire guarda che se compri tramite A
puoi risparmiare X.
Come poi nelle zone periferiche o nei paesini
alla fine un'applicazione così funziona come Uber, come Glovo
come tutti questi perché di queste realtà non arrivano.
Cioè tu pensa nel paesino, non lo so, in Sardegna
Uber non andrà mai o forse sì tra X anni
però ci sono macchine e magari
gente che non ha niente da fare.
Eh sì, fanno il loro Uber interno.
Certo.
Dai.
Mauri direi, posso chiamarti Mauri?
Sì, come no.
Come no.
Ma dai direi che top, vai.
Poi ci vediamo anche prossimamente live, sicuramente.
Sì, sì.
Prima di Natale.
Quello sicuro.
Che c'è anche il tuo armadio da sistemare entro fine anno
quello te l'ho promesso e va sistemato l'armadio.
Ok, va bene, va bene.
Dai, ti giro io dopo mezzanotte il documento
che ho due o tre cose da fare prima della mezza
proprio di corsa e poi vi dico a quelli
a quali lavorano sulla trascrizione e l'aggiornamento del doc
e te lo giro in WhatsApp.
Va bene.
Io domani faccio la verifica su Twitter
su come poter quadrare questa uscita subito
e poi già domani in serata se sei tranquillo ti chiamo
e teniamo le somme.
Assolutamente, assolutamente.
Perfetto.
Va bene, va bene.
Dai.
Grazie mille Francesco.
Sicurati, a domani.
Una buona serata.
Anche a te.
Ciao Mauri.
Ciao.